[Music]
every damn day today I'm gonna catch you
up on the craziest internet you
might have missed Jillian throw up that
first headline this one comes from
Denver Colorado
a polyamorous events planner plans to
break the record for the largest orgy
which is not what her client was
imagining when he requested an exciting
Bar Mitzvah how do we feel a thousand
people yes so she plans to have a
thousand people all have sex together
she is a 29 year old woman from Colorado
I would never go to an orgy I've
disappointed pretty much everyone I've
ever liked I don't want to do that on a
larger scale thousand people we're
inviting like a hundred something to my
wedding and it's a total nightmare I
can't imagine what this is supposed to
look like and also it's you know how bad
that's got a smell it's gotta be you
ever look at a porn clip and like think
about what's that smell like don't do it
no ruins it'll ruin you I mean you have
to then apologize to a thousand people
[Laughter]
yeah it's just a like a receiving line
of I'm sorry I think that's why when I
was in an orgy oh yes I was it was like
I had some people over my apartment and
it was just friends hanging out and then
someone came over started mixing drinks
a couple more people can't started
coming over and then I turned around and
people were eating each other out on my
couch and I was like what what is going
on drive into the party like literally
it was maybe 15 minutes 50 minutes was
it a plan orgy or didn't I don't think
it was but you know
now they're my friends and I was like
what guys like what this is so crazy I
literally thought it was like telling
people like guys what is going on this
is crazy and then everyone was like like
everyone talk to individuals like I
don't know this was crazy and then I
would see them in the the thing and then
it was it moved into my room and I was
like this is crazy and then I was like
alright well I should try it like I'm in
college to try this out and then I made
eye contact with my friend while we both
had a titty in our mouths and I was like
guys we got to stop this is like man we
got to stop and then everyone's like
whoa like slowly like lifting themselves
out from whatever they were doing
they're like oh Jordan is uncomfortable
Jordan one that doesn't do this and I
was like yeah it's like a little weird
and they left and I'm pretty sure they
just continued did you talk to them at
like was it weird the next day I've
never spoken about it it's so damn bored
I've never been involved or yeah I've
got invited to a couple but I was like
I'm cool with the rest of my things -
with the rest of the roots too much I
don't even like that style of porn it's
too much to focus on it's like where are
you going or I'm over here and that
looks fun over there I got a greedy I
can't hear I love that Ryan set you up
to explain why you're wearing and you're
like no this is just I'm just gonna wear
costume with no explanation every
episode that's fine
truly yeah true this is also how we
found out about it which is just no
reason surprise or die's down that's not
my costume all right throw that next
headline to pro dart players have
accused each other of farting onstage
during a match everyone is shocked that
the standards at the National dart
competition weren't already this low
that's like one of those sports where
it's like you're really bad at it and
then you have a drink and you're a
little bit better and then you have
another drink and you're a little bit
better and then you have another drink
and you're very bad again
it's like one of those sports like pool
or sex one of the players said quote in
the article it'll take me two nights to
lose this smell if I laugh really really
hard I saw him everywhere fire on set no
[Laughter]
that's something I have to think about
if I'm out in public and I'm like if
you're having a very good time you will
probably like Chris you got me the fire
well it'll be loud yeah it's wildly the
actor who used to play Barney the
Dinosaur is now a tantric sex therapist
well before he was just working pro bono
[Laughter]
we should never find out anything about
any children's performer or actor
anybody ever is are you gonna have sex
or be attracted to the kids no put on
the costume never do an interview don't
speak to anybody I don't want to know
this yeah and he didn't have to tell him
nobody know it's so true we don't need
kiss he was truly in the costume there
would be no way to know that he was
Barney I don't want to know about this
guy I read about his new career I don't
care about his old that's XA mageot just
because he played Barney once mm-hmm he
he's a human too and you know what
Barney had has had sex barney is he's
probably had sex and exercise kids yeah
that was an infant son that they cut
from the show do you think he boned baby
back this is all so horrible it's
horrible just to know that there's
people in there
do you ever see like you're on Times
Square and you see like an Elmo take a
coffee break
something and you're like this is the
most depressing thing ever
wait what if they were having tantric
sex with each other
he's a tantric sex therapist so like
people come to him and like pay him
money in him you know supposedly I was
just thinking about a tantric sex orgy
where everyone's just kind of napping on
each other that truly would take hours
is their whole thing is like yeah like
sting has sex for like days apparently
is that crazy
what the hell just move it's better if
you move he's just doing it wrong wait
what are you talking about it that's
move you don't move I think there's a
lot of what's it called breathing
Kundalini breathing sure get it over
with we got to watch Great British Bake
show how long do you guys wait after
having sex until you like it's a coating
we time to open up the computer and
watch something I don't watch things my
computer so you mean like what old man
are you
you don't watch stuff on your computer I
have a television what do you watch it's
bigger where I should be fired from our
web show right hey show on my television
or on the what we're on the Internet
okay we're gonna play a little headline
Mad Libs so Jillian throw up that first
headline I like these oh good that we've
done so try to guess the blank so the
headline is pardon me turkey is this
stool taken scientists turned poultry
blank into feel whoo oh yeah yeah it's
definitely poop she said is poop on the
board
yes turkey legs like when we said use
the whole animal
[Applause]
also the next one a parent was accused
of wearing a blank to sway his son's
football game small shorts jagged shorts
jackie-joyce what testicle well I think
he was jogging shorts one testicle was
word I'm wrong I think he's wearing a
referees uniform
[Music]
let's see jockstrap all right show us
that answer all right all right last one
okay here we go
Frankie Muniz says his blank turned on
his faucet and flooded his okay so
Jordan I don't know it's a I didn't
miss on the Internet there's also lots
of videos in the internet where they
turn on the sink and then they make from
it and then they turn out yeah I can't
this guy just didn't learn the off trick
and ruined malcolm in the middle'
mansion I do like the idea of you
watching like cat fails on your teeth
Frankie meow
[Applause]
that was great that was heaven little
party you know those comments are gonna
be massed about they're all gonna be I'd
watched Natasha fart yeah Wow best joke
I've ever heard where some guys got into
a huge debate or the said about who's
the most evil villain of South Park I
don't know those guys where they're very
good-looking I could tell you that slim
Aaron says this feels like a Christmas
episode of a 90s hit TV show honestly
that makes me feel good about thank you
slip Wow yeah I can't tell if it's good
or bad it's bad TV show there was
nothing Christmas on the set he was
wearing a sweater people wouldn't just
like leave a mean comment for no reason
it'd be crazy all the moments are always
so thoughtful and kind so uh
Lemus one of those thank you for
watching every damn day catch us also on
Twitter for extra damn day someday
[Music]